charlie morton he is eight and three on
the year 364 era could easily have made
the all-star team especially the way
he's pitched in recent days so a full
count for brandon lau
and a check swing he went around and
charlie morton's knight is off to a good
start
oh two on the way
swing and a miss two strikeouts for
charlie morton in a perfect one two
three top of the first michael walker on
the mound tonight for the race coming
off a really good outing against the
cleveland indians
one and two to count the pitch on its
way to albies and he swings in grounds
off of the glove of waka to walls who
makes the catch glove flips the second
and they force out freeman but that's
the only out they're going to be able to
get alby's hustling up the line so it's
a fielder's choice that goes one
to six to five
man at first base here's
all-star joey wendell hitting 275 with
seven homers 33 knocked in to their
history the one-two pitch is grounded
sharply by the dive of freeman and down
the right field line for a base hit
around second on his way to third is
meadows the throw to second is going to
be cut off and sliding in safely is joey
wendell and the rays have runners at
second and third
with nobody out his window picks up
double number 22. kevin caremeyer
obviously they're raised in a really
good situation man on second and third i
wonder if they're even discussing a
possible bunt situation there's a
swinging left side this is going to
trickle through for a base hit scoring
his meadows wendell will only be able to
advance the third
as he had to make sure that ball got
through so caremeyer
with a little tapper through the left
side the raiser on the board first
it's one nothing hey the graves defensed
him as a pull guy all the way ground
ball third
a look to the plate but the play is
going to be at first as wendell scores
riley had that play in front of him took
a glance at the plate early in the game
decided to go to first to get the shore
out and the rays pick up their second
run the 3-2 pitch where the runners
going a check swing and it's outside
ball four
close pitch went brandon lou's way and
stopping at third kiermeier at second
base walls and the race of the base is
full
for g-mon choi we'll see if rick granitz
wants to come out have a chat morton
about to make his 33rd pitch of the
inning and it was a beauty he needed
that he strikes out troy where the base
is loaded but tampa bay strikes for two
in the top of the second inning
taylor walls
will be the hitter he had a good at bat
drew a walk in the
second inning on the three two to wall
slice to the gap left center field
giving chase's heredia he's a good
fielder reaches out can't get it he
knocks it down zanino rounding second on
his way to third and up the second is
walls with a double and the race gets
second and third with only one away
looking into kevin smith they settle up
on what they want to throw one two got
him looking strike three
curve ball right off the table and into
the mid of kevin smith and he freezes
waka chatted briefly with austin before
the games how was your all-star break he
said man i'm dead tired is it what
happened went back home to mississippi
said my house was a mess he said i spent
two days pressure washing he's going
and a high fly ball hit a mile high
straightaway center by her back to the
raw we are tied
maybe pressure rushing is just what the
doctor ordered he hit that ball
high and deep to straight away center to
tie it up at two as a beautiful swing
beautiful result
hammered the ball fouled down down to
third base line earlier in the count
got another pitch to handle and didn't
miss it so 2-2 here's dansby
as this ball is hammered to deep left
that ball's got a shot
atlanta ga the braves enjoy their first
lead
well dansby continues his hot hitting
got a pitch he could handle and
got just enough of it to get over the
left get it over the left wall
[Applause]
homer here
and all of a sudden swanson now with 16
long balls
morton made 33 pitches in the second
this one is shot the other way into left
toward the corner that ball's going to
get out homer on the opposite way for
g-man joy his fourth of the year
and on the first pitch in the fifth
inning
joy
has headed out
to tie this game
what a job of answering from the tampa
bay rays right here g-man choi
doing an unbelievable job going the
opposite way with what was a pretty good
offering here by charlie morton watch
where this pitch ends up i mean that's
down
and you really don't see that ball
elevated very often g-man choi able to
stay on that pitch keeps his head on the
swing top of the order for atlanta
almonte freeman and albie's do up
and the first pitch whacked into right
field by almante there's a good start
he's one for three freeman's average at
275 boy it's been a long climb for
freddy after a slow start
has stepped right in and has been great
for him three balls two strikes for
freddie
swing and a high fly ball
deep right did he get enough he did
two run homer
that takes care of the scoreless streak
and the braves are back in front
the braves have hit three homers tonight
they lead it five to three well we
talked about freddy's career numbers in
the second half we talked about
everybody having to pick up the slack
with ronald being hurt and it starts
with that guy
yeah fastball
inner third
thigh high
[Applause]
trying to put it where he wants to when
it's in that spot now here's juan de
franco's had a rough night left-handed
we'll see we can do right-handed
97 and it's sky deep toward the right
field corner that's going to be over the
head of almante
extra bases for franco digging for three
and he is gonna make it easily
franco a three base hit
into the right field corner and boy he
turned it on he had that play in front
of him
and he hit another gear well you talk
about his speed and you talk about all
the tools that this kid has you know the
power and the skill set that's the first
time i've seen that speed on display
franco now at third meadows trying to
get him home
this one's skied to left
matzia will make the catch the tag
bronco heads to the plate and he will
make it easily
standing up and the rays turn that
triple
into a run and now it's a one-run game
freddie freeman homer last time up he
has a first inning single two he hit
into a lot of bad luck
and does that
whacks it right up the middle with a
two-strike count
you know hit into a lot of bad luck had
some bad at bats here and there and
he'll be the first to tell you but
we haven't seen too many bad fats lately
so far the best year of austin riley's
young
major league career freddie leeds there
he goes and the pitch lined into left
field that's down for a hit freeman's
going to take third here's the throw
it's high
riley scampers back to first and the
braves have a two out threat and now
riley leads it first with a 3-2 pitch
there he goes and a line drive right
field base here the run is in another
two-strike hit this time from garcia and
the braves take a two-run lead
one out for brandon lau oh for three
with a walk
he lines up fastball into center for a
base hit
so the rays get a base runner
with one out of the eight wander franco
now
there's a triple in a run score tonight
shoots this one into left there's a base
hit
up to second base goes lau
so franco goes the other way
and has himself a base hit and a two
head night we are ready to go lau and
franco are going to be running
and here is the payoff pitch to meadows
line drive right field base head
rounding third is lao and he will come
in to score
to third base goes franco and meadows
delivers her back to a run run game it's
6'5 atlanta and a big hit by meadows
first and third here is joey wendell
that's a high chop
and a quick throw to first that is not
in time and a base hit
and the rays
have tied this game
meadows already with two runs spatted in
and each of his last
two plate appearances
here we go 3-1 and a live drive base hit
into right field
the run will score throw to the plate is
not going to be in time phillips in head
first and the rays take the lead
7-6
boy another great at-bat right here by
austin meadows gets himself into a very
favorable count able to drive that
fastball out to right field and now
monte
having no shot at the speedy brett
phillips have played
peterson making his atlanta braves debut
as a pinch hitter and he chops it toward
the middle
to throw to first and the rays win this
one in 10.
peterson going after the first pitch
fairbanks comes on to close it out
and the rays win this one 7-6
in 10 innings they pick up their 54th
win of the year